our next speaker is my nemesis
so
so matt um
you may have seen recently he just
tweeted like an hour ago that everyone
comes to him complaining about
tensorflow bugs and i'm one of those
people and so
today um matt's gonna tell us like how
amazing tensorflow and keras is but what
he actually does at hugging face is also
maintains the tensorflow side of the
transformers library
and um
he's a great speaker and has a lot of
great humor so i'm looking forward to
plenty of jokes
no promises
all right so let me get this stream
yeah we'll disappear from the stream and
okay so this fingers crossed as well
g'day this is lewis
hi so this is going to be a quick talk
about
new features we've added to the hugging
face libraries
particularly for tensorflow and keras
users
so there's one particularly important
feature i want to show today which saves
me a huge amount of repetitive
boilerplate code and it also improves
the memory usage and performance of my
training by a very large factor
um
so to start i'm just going to set up a
standard sort of training room
and then we'll see how we can use this
method
to save us a lot of effort and to
improve our performance significantly so
we're just going to start
we're going to start by loading a data
set so we need the load dataset function
from the datasets library
and the dataset i'm going to use
is the
cola dataset from the blue benchmark
oops i load dataset
so if you look at this data set um it's
very straightforward there's only three
columns
um the sentence the text the input for
each sample the label
which is just a zero or one so this is
just a simple binary classification task
the model is predicting uh whether a
sentence is valid english or not
and then the third column is just the
unique index for each sample so this is
pretty much as straightforward as nlp
tasks get but even here this method is
going to be really useful
um
so what do we do when we have our data
first thing we do in almost all nlp
tasks is we tokenize it so we're going
to import our tokenizer
and
today feels like a distilbert kind of
day so we'll use our model as distilbert
so tokenizer equals auto tokenizer
and
okay
so that should give us the distillery
tokenizer
and now
um there's a cool trick for applying
these things to there together for
tokenizing data sets
and that is
to use the dataset.map method and i'll
show you here if we just make a quick
tokenization function
and
all the tokenization function does
is it just tokenizes the sentence key of
whatever data set you pass it because
sent the sentence
key is the key that contains all the
input text for each of these samples
then all we need to do to tokenize all
of our data sets
is to use the dataset.map method
and map that function
sorry
tokenizer and here we go and now
we should have our data sets
so a cool thing here is that when you
use map
um
if you if your function returns a
dictionary all of the keys of that
dictionary are going to be added to the
data set as columns so the tokenizer
returns a dictionary with input ids and
with attention mask keys
and both of those are now
in the data set as columns and that
means that all of our data is sort of
kept together
um we can pick out any single sample and
see both its original text and its input
ids and its attention mask and so on
um so it's it's really handy for you
know kind of organizing your data this
way um but that's not that that feature
has been around for a while there's
something new i want to show you
and that is the 2tf dataset method
so
why do we need this method so
let's to see why let's look at the
input ids so i'm just going to figure
out the training data set
i'm going to pick at the input ids here
i'll just put that in a variable called
tokens so the input ids are the tokens
that come out of the tokenizer and if
you look at tokens we see it's just a
list of lists so each sample has been
turned into a list of integers
like this
and now if we just check the length so
i'm just going to say
len sample for sample in token so that's
going to give us the length of every
single sample
we see here the lengths and they vary so
there's
um
quite a range of lengths they're mostly
around the same length because they're
all like one sentence
but even one sentence can have a varying
number of words and each of those words
can be split into a varying number of
tokens so there's quite a lot of
variability in terms of how many tokens
there are
in fact if we look at the max
we'll see that one sentence has ended up
as 47 tokens and if we look at the mean
we'll get that from the statistics
library
we could have also also just divide some
by length that would work as well
um
we see the mean is 11.5 so if the max is
47 tokens but the mean is 11.5
um
the longest sample in that data set is
almost four times in fact slightly more
than four times as long as the average
um
and that's a problem because
if we want to turn this data set into
one single tensor or one single array
we're going to need to pad every sample
to the same length
uh and particularly um when i want to
train with keras it's really really
helpful if i can get the data in one
single array that's something i really
want to do because then i can just pass
it to keras and keras will handle you
know it will sample from the data it
will shuffle the data it will make
batches for me i don't have to worry
about any of that
um
but it's pretty much it's pretty
difficult to do that here
um because if we have to pad all the
samples to the length 47 it's on pretty
much three quarters of our data is going
to be padding tokens when we're done
and that means our data set is going to
be four times bigger than it needs to be
which is going to be a big waste of
memory
and it's also going to slow down
computation enormously
um
in the case of the cola data set i mean
these are not huge samples even 47
tokens is not that big language models
can handle inputs from 128 to 512 tokens
very easily and there's more specialized
models can go way beyond that
um
but
these
even though we might you know we could
sort of get away with padding everything
to the maximum length for cola
um
it's
still a big waste and for other data
sets it's an enormous waste and a waste
that would probably make the task
impossible if you had to do it
um
so in general padding every sample to
the maximum length is not something we
want to be doing regularly but if we
don't do that then we can't put all the
data in a single array and that means we
can't pass it easily to model.fit we end
and what i personally ended up doing was
writing generator functions a lot of the
time and that generator would have to
handle
shuffling and sampling and batching all
the data for me and it just meant i was
writing the same code over and over and
over for every task i wanted to do i
would have to write this huge generator
and it was a big source of like you know
small bugs would often be in the
generator and it would be i'm just a big
annoyance to debug them
um
so what i want is some way that i can
pass the data to tensorflow
without having to write all that
boilerplate code um but with also
without padding every sample to the
maximum length of the data set i only
want to pad each batch the minimum
amount required to make that one single
batch a tensor
so the solution we came up with is the
two tf dataset method and i'll show you
how that works here um but the first
thing we're going to need before we use
it is a collation function so a data
collater
is a function that puts together samples
into a batch so you can write your own
but we've got
a range that covers pretty much all of
the common
collation methods you would need to use
so probably the single most common
is the data collater with padding and
that's exactly what we need here we need
the data collater with padding data
collater
and then we created likes and we
initialize it like so we say
data collater with padding
it needs the tokenizer and the reason it
needs the tokenizer is that different
models have different padding styles
and so it needs your model's tokenizer
so it knows how to pad data in the way
that your model expects and the second
thing it needs is it needs to know that
you want tensorflow tenses back
and because these data collaterals and
our tokenizers are all framework
agnostic which means they're designed to
work with both pi torch and tensorflow
and even with jacks
um
so you need to be very careful that you
tell it and the the type of tensor you
want back so you don't accidentally get
pie torch tensors or some other horrible
undesirable thing in your lovely
tensorflow code
um so if we run that we now have our
data collater
and now we can convert the data set like
so we just say we'll start with just the
training data set so we'll just say
uh
tokenized data sets train and then we
call the 2tf dataset method
and what it needs to know is it needs to
know
the columns
which is going to be which columns of
the data set are we going to be passing
to our model
um
so we can see here that those are almost
always the columns that were added by
the tokenizer um
so we can just
put that in there
so those are the columns we want to go
as our input and we can also add label
columns so these are the um the columns
that are going to be passed as the label
in each batch
and that is
labels it's also um you'll see it's
marked as label but our data collators
rename the column label to labels
because almost all models expect the
input to actually be called labels
just a minor quirk that will be the the
data collector will take care of it for
you so don't worry about that too much
but just be aware of that as an
interesting quirk of most transformer
models um
and then the other things we need are we
just need to tell it that we want the
data to be shuffled and we want a batch
size of 16. so these are arguments that
you would normally pass to fit and but
when you're generating your data outside
of it for example with a data generator
these are the things you need to take
care of yourself
and
the 2tf dataset method needs to know
whether you're shuffling and what batch
size to be to output for you
um but i've tried as much as possible to
keep these methods close to the same
keras arguments so you just move these
arguments from fit
to two tf data set and it should work in
the same way
and then the final argument we need is
the collate function
um so the argument is collate function
collate fn and we just pass it the data
collateral we initialized already and of
course i just realized
we actually need to save that as a
variable and not just run it on its own
so we run that this is this is just
tensorflow initialization don't worry
about it
and if we look at our data set we see we
get this nice data set out so
it's um each batch this is showing you
sort of the shape of each batch that's
going to come out of the data set so you
can see that each batch is an input
dictionary the keys are attention mask
and input ids and it also gives you the
shapes and the types um for those and
then the second element of the tuple is
a label here
and it has it's just seeing a
one-dimensional vector with shape 16.
so that's exactly what we want
and the great thing is this data set is
just ready to go so now all we need to
do is
compile and fit our model
so
uh we'll just get our optimizer so it's
from tensorflow to keras.optimizers
um
and the reason we are doing it this way
and not just calling atom by string is
of course that we need um significantly
lower learning rates for adam
than the default atom by default has a
learning rate of one e minus three but
with transformers something like five e
minus five is usually much more
appropriate and so that's almost 20
times lower in fact exactly 20 times
lower
and the second thing we'll need
um
is to import our loss
and our loss of course is sparse
categorical cross entropy because we're
doing a classification task
um
and again
this is something you can call by string
and in when you're calling model.compile
you can just pass these as strings
but it's not advisable to do that with
the express categorical cross entry loss
and the reason for that is that all
hugging face models output logits
not probabilities so jits are the values
before you apply a soft max to them
um so a soft max turns raw logits into
your output probabilities
um
and so you you should be aware that um
the d the sparse categorical cross
entropy loss in keras expects
probabilities by default and if you want
to pass it logits you need to make sure
to tell it that that's what indeed what
you're passing it um so that means you
need to import the loss and then set
that argument correctly but now we have
both of those
uh we can import our model
and we can
so
so this is going to be a four sequence
classification model because this is a
sequence classification task
and our model is going to be
i'm just going to initialize it with a
standard from pre-trained method
and we're using um i'm going to make
sure that of course we use the same
model here that we tokenized our data
with up here
um
so this point everything's been
initialized it's just telling us that
some some layers were newly initialized
because it added a classifier layer
um and that we're going to need to train
this model before it can actually
classify anything and that's of course
exactly what we expect so now we can
simply compile the model we have our
loss we have our
optimizer so that all works
and now
the beauty is we can just pass this
straight our train data set that we made
with the 2tf dataset method
we can pass it straight to model.fit
give it a second to compile and put
everything together and there's our
model
so
this is a very quick script there's a
very quick script there's very little um
i'm going to set a very quick crypt
there by accident and i don't think
we're burying anything
but
the
key thing to take away is just that
there's
very little code here but this
setup will give you
minimal memory usage at maximum
performance because the data is only
being padded just in time so each batch
is coming out and it's being padded at
the very last moment and only to
the minimum size needed for that batch
and that means that we're not wasting
any padding tokens um whereas if we
padded the whole data set uh
you know we would have a huge amount of
padding tokens and everything would just
be much slower and we'd be bloating our
memory usage massively
and without the 2tf dataset method we
would need to write a generator and
collater ourselves
to do all of this and it would be a huge
amount of boilerplate code that would be
a source of bugs and just a big waste of
time
so with this method which i recommend
using in essentially um every
keras training setup you're doing
whenever you're using uh transformers
models and uh hugging face data sets
and you just call this one method and
you get a data set that's just ready to
go straight in model that fit and so you
get
clean results
uh
top performance and a minimal of
wasted effort and boilerplate code
so that's the method i wanted to show
you today and i hope you find it useful
so thank you very much
hey everyone
so thank you very much for that talk
matt that was super nice um yeah that
was very insightful thanks
we we also appreciate the little d get
play to which
it's important to be clear where my
loyalties lie
cool so we have a couple of questions um
so let's see the
it is a kind of great question i think
about the um the way data collaterals
work so i'm just going to put it up on
the screen so
the question is does it make sense to
sort the data by length so we get less
padding per batch
so that's that's a clever idea that
would actually work you you would then
you get these batches that would only be
padded a small amount the problem then
is you're not sampling your data
randomly so every all data would end up
being batched together with the same
other samples
so you would not get a random shuffle of
your data set if you did that and that
means that would mean especially if
you're training for multiple epochs and
your training would start to have very
weird properties
because of that lack of random sampling
so i i don't think it would work in
practice you might get away with it with
one epoch of training maybe
but even then i'm not sure i recommend
it
great
so then we have another
question which is about zero shot
models so if you have something like a
zero shot model how does the tensorflow
auto model for sequence classification
change
okay that's a really good question um
so in the example i used here i started
with distilbert and distilbert is a
language model not a sequence
classification model and so when you put
distilbert in tf auto model for sequence
classification it basically sticks a
classifier head on the on the like very
last layer of distillery and just
randomly initializes those weights
so that will not be capable of zero shot
classification
so if you want to do zero shot
classification you need to start with a
checkpoint and that was trained on some
sequence classification task in the past
so that it will have the sequence
classification head
and then you do zero shot classification
by just applying that model uh directly
to your data without training and the
hope is that if it was trained on data
in the past that is relatively similar
to your data then you will get and zero
shot classification out of it
um
but that you will never get zero shot
classification from
a base language model like distillery
base
just because it has never done sequence
classification before
so it always has to be trained with some
label data
awesome
yeah i think what you can also do is use
like natural language inference as the
task which is kind of like an elaborate
classification task
if i remember correctly that's actually
how the zeroshot pipeline is based on
so you could do that in tensorflow
pretty easily oh yeah yeah if you can
reframe the question as a natural
language question then get completion
out of that that would also work
okay so we have another question which
is maybe coming also back from my talk
um so
imagine i have like an imbalanced data
set um do i need to worry about
preserving the imbalance like the class
distribution per batch or is this not a
problem
that's a good question uh
so i would
i don't think it's necessary to
perfectly balance pert batch uh lewis i
don't like would you agree or disagree
with that i think is i agree i might
over sample over the whole data set i
might over sample the rarer classes
um i don't think i would care that much
about balancing every single batch
exactly and each batch is only maybe 16
to 30 examples on a single gpu right so
i think this problem is going to kind of
wash out in the
approach
remember that we trained plenty of
classification model and imagenet which
has like 1000 levels and it's the batch
size is not 1000 so like
but it is definitely it can be very
helpful to oversample the rare classes
um even if you don't put them in every
single batch to still sample them more
often than they would randomly appear
that is definitely a method people use
and that works well
cool and maybe i can ask you a question
no no it's going to be fine so
i think one of the really exciting
features um in the tensorflow api that
you've been developing has been this
kind of conversion of data sets into
tensorflow data sets
um at least myself this was always a
pain point in like bridging the gap from
you know the hugging face ecosystem to
the keras one and so i was just kind of
curious like what's on the say roadmap
for tensorflow um in transformers
oh god there's a lot of things there's a
there's a huge notion document of things
you want to add um
so okay and things that are big on the
roadmap is we want to get a lot of
vision transformers working well in
tensorflow so those have been we've
added some recently and we're planning
to add several more there's been some
great contributions and from people in
the community
um
so transformers are not just natural
language processing objects that's kind
of where these have started and they see
the most use um but they're getting
extremely good results um for vision
tasks as well
um
and so
we want to make a push because i like a
lot of vision people and people are
working computer vision use tensorflow
and keras um we want to like
make um make the ecosystem kind of
available for them as well
um
other than that
we've got there's like
there's a huge list of fixes
particularly involving um
kind of like big performance boosts for
example generating text with tensorflow
language models and we're going to make
that a compilable tensorflow function
which is going to give it a huge
performance boost and hopefully even
beat pi pytorch which is kind of my
secret internal goal whenever i start
doing these things
um i want that to i want that to end up
faster
um they're like xla compilable and it's
going to really upset everyone else at
the company
we whenever another question are coming
from the forum
uh i understand that padding enables
patching data points together but too
many padding tokens make the competition
very slow what is the attention mask for
i haven't fully understood the purpose
of padding and attention masks and the
impact and speed
okay so that's a really good question so
the reason for padding is that if
samples are different lengths if you
want to put them in an array the array
like the array is going to be square or
rectangular basically it's going to
expect that every sample is the same
length
so when we pad we basically put these
null padding tokens onto the end of
every sample
and that those are just there to
basically bring them up to the same
length but we don't really want them to
affect the computation at all and that's
what the attention mask is for
so the attention mask is one and it's
the the attention mask is the same shape
as the input array and it contains ones
for real tokens and zeros for padding
tokens and it basically tells the model
to ignore all the tokens with a zero in
the attention mask
um
so
you uh you can like i said pad the whole
data set but then you end up with your
attention mask mostly being zeros at
most of your samples just being padding
tokens you know stretching off into the
distance and that's just very slow and
very inefficient because
padding tokens do still waste a bit of
memory into computation time even though
we try and get the model to ignore them
um so it's ideal to use as few of them
as possible and that's what this method
is all about
awesome
do we have any more questions silva
i think we did we asked someone about
the maximum length
yes i think okay so we have no more
questions
great thank you
thanks once again matt and i'll hand
over to everyone to introduce the next
speaker